what do you what is the next book going
to be about is the next book
how could you possibly expand on
everything that you went through over
the past 20 years to create this book
believe it or not it wouldn't be that
difficult um
first of all for your listeners if
they're
if they don't know anything about the
book i don't want it to be oversold
it doesn't answer the biggest questions
it raises
basically that's why it took so long i
kept looking for a smoking gun to prove
the thesis is there's more than one in
here and
my agent kept telling me after like the
first five or six years you've got
enough stuff you don't have to prove
everything you you definitely
completely blow apart the official
versions of
of the manson murders the the reason for
the murders
uh the fact that there were more people
involved
in the commission of them and the
manipulation of manson that's
huge that's enough but i was never
satisfied because i always felt like i
was you know one day away
and going on and on so that's what keeps
you going right
yeah for better or worse so what what
i've gotten since the book came out
is i've gotten a lot more substantiation
it's like building a pyramid and i'm
almost at the top
and i'm thinking i told dan my
collaborator a week or two ago i said
i think if i can get a few more things
in the next month
then we can just i can stop and we can
go and start on it
uh if not i do think we have enough
anyway even if i don't get it but i'll
still want a little more time
uh we didn't write anything about the
saran
uh case in the book the assassin of
robert f kennedy the assassination
occurred about a year and a month before
the tape murders in los angeles and the
same cops
same attorneys same players and
i uncovered a lot of new and pretty
compelling information
proving that um sir ham was
a manchurian candidate somebody who was
programmed to be in the in the pantry
believe me i'm not the first one to do
that a lot of really respected writers
and authors
have been trying to get this case
reopened for years i have some new
information
but we couldn't link it to the main
psychiatrist in our book who
we alleged manipulated manson he was a
good candidate but i said without
linking it
it would have been two or three whole
chapters that wouldn't have
stayed on our narrative through line in
the book
so when we do the new book i think i
will be
able to link it and that that's one
thing for instance that'll be in the new
book and also the jonestown case you
know with the jim jones and the
mass suicides and guyana all this stuff
happened in the petty hearse kidnapping
right so it's basically just kind of
undoing
unraveling a lot of stuff that are
pretty much
landmark historic crimes in the united
states
that occurred in the 60s and i tried to
stop in the 70s right
that were presented to us by media you
know a media that was complicit with the
government and the
cia to cover up truth and realities of
how
many of these things were provoked how
frustrating is it
knowing that there is evidence out there
that basically
would give you the answers yeah this
book like the
the what is it the guy tex watson
there's those recordings of him there's
tapes that are
somewhere that you just can't get your
hands on but it must be so frustrating
to know they're there and they exist
yeah that actually the book kind of ends
with me uh
trying to get those tapes and i won't
spoil the story but
um that was incredibly frustrating i
hope that comes through in the book
because
i helped number one i discovered these
tapes existed that they were in a safe
in an attorney's closet in texas that he
had kept since november of 1969
and it was what he had told me were 20
hours of audio
tape of tex watson manson's kind of
right-hand man who did most of the
killing and all the murders you know
manson was absent from the murder scenes
right the second night of the
the la bianca murders he tied them up
and then told the others what to do but
left before the murders happened
so text before anyone knew who he was
who the manson family was they weren't
in the papers yet
only the police consider them suspects
um had been detained he had fled home to
his little town in texas where he was
from
and the lapd wanted to interview him as
a suspect
so they called up his cousin who was a
lawyer in the small town that he lived
in
and the the i'm sure
excuse me he was the sheriff of that
town and the cousin agreed to take his
nephew or
uncle nephew into custody while the two
lapd cops came down and he called the
the lawyer bill boyd and bill boyd came
over and said i'll represent
him and he said what are these guys
coming down here to talk to you about he
said i have no idea
he goes well something happened in los
angeles and he said he beats me
so the two cops came down and sat down
with a lawyer
uh texas parents and his uncle the
sheriff
and they said where were you on the
night of august 8 1969
august 9 1969 and the others put it
together and someone said are you
talking about the sharon tape murder
and he said i nothing i never knew or
nothing to do with that
so um bill boyd said
to the others can i have a few moments
alone with them and they said yeah so
they left
and then he said to taxi charles was his
real name
he said charles this is pretty serious
allegations
i want you to think about it and then
answer
as honestly as you can uh
these these detectives questions and
i'll represent you and make sure
you don't go to the death penalty
because he already knew
he could tell that he was getting caught
up in some lies
so they left text alone for an hour or
two and then
bill went back to see charles and
again alone just one on one he said you
know what these men are
here for and he goes you know that girl
sharon tate that actress that they
mentioned he goes
yeah he goes i killed her and he said
okay
i'm going to tell them you're not
talking to them but that i'm going to
represent you
so he said you're done with my client
you can come back you know with the
subpoena or whatever but right now he's
my client i don't want him answering any
questions
so then he went and recorded charles for
two days
just telling everything about how he met
madison what other people were around
and i called him this lawyer in 2008 i
think to interview him
and he made the mistake during the
interview
of telling me you know i have these
tapes that nobody's ever heard
and they were before anything had been
written in the newspaper so they're
probably like the purest account of what
really happened charles was so honest
and he just
talked for about 20 hours and he said he
even described other murders that the
police had never learned about
the minute he said that i thought number
one he's implicating his
former client who's always your client
in other murders
and number two he's never going to let
me hear those tapes
so when i said so you're talking about
murders that the police hadn't
discovered and he said yeah other
murders and then all of a sudden he
realized what he was saying
and goes not that charles had committed
but the charles was aware the others had
done
and i said well who were they goes why
haven't listened to them and
i guess then it was like 40 years
because i know there were a couple
bikers they killed and
i was already looking into these missing
bikers who had been last seen with the
group in death valley
and i said mr boyd is there any chance i
could come down and listen to the tapes
and then he got really nervous because
then all of a sudden he's realizing he
violated his
confidentiality so well you know um i
couldn't do anything without charles
permission and but i'll i'll ask him
and then that was it he wouldn't take my
phone calls
his secretary would always say oh he had
no time to see him he's traveling and
after like three months of blowing me
off
i told the secretary to tell him i was
going to write to charles in prison
tell him what he said and ask for an
interview and she had just told me he
was in china
on business so she said i'll tell him
and she hung up and the phone rang a
minute later
and my caller id said mckinney texas
and it was him on the phone don't you
dare write to my client
if you if you say that i said all that
all deny it god damn it i said but you
said it all on audio tape he said
i didn't give you permission to tape me
i said not only did you give me
permission you did it on tape
god damn it so he died
two months later of a heart attack on a
treadmill at about age
68 or seven i think i hope that had
nothing to do with it oh you definitely
did
long story short the tapes went into his
firm had gone bankrupt
so they went to the bankruptcy court and
for about two years i tried to get the
court to release the tapes to me
rather than put them up for auction or
destroy them or whatever they were going
to do
and again it's a very long story but
i'll keep it short the the trustee in
charge of them
ended up contacting the deputy d.a in
los angeles
who knew what i was doing and really
wanted the tapes too
and was kind of advising me and i said
if you don't think i'm legit you can
get in touch with him so she did and
then of course
stupidly i was naive enough to think
that
that wouldn't ruin my chances but sure
enough patrick shakira
arranged to get the tapes from her and
he had always promised me that the
minute
if he got them first i would sit down
with him and listen to them for the
first time who's patrick
he was the deputy d.a who was in charge
of all the parole hearings of the manson
family
so he started he called me up really
excited he said i can't believe it
they're going to release the tapes to me
but we can't let the press know because
if the press finds out and tex
finds out he's going to stop it but
somebody down there in texas found out
oh no
the the trustee told watson's current
attorney because she had to
i don't know why patrick thought that
wasn't going to happen so then watson
immediately went to court
to stop the tapes from being released
and then there was a two or three year
process from the county court to state
court to the state supreme court where
they finally decided that the tapes
should be released
and then the lapd and the da's office
got them and then they wouldn't talk to
me
anymore and to this day they're sitting
in a vault because i believe those tapes
tell the truth
about why things happen how they really
happened and who was behind the scenes
manipulating manson
you